[Music]
[Applause]
ESPN's Reese Davis host of ESPN college
game day in Tuscaloosa with gang
Saturday for LSU in Alabama and once
again they'll be on the road with uh
Athens Georgia Old Miss at Georgia reys
thanks for joining us um we've been
talking about Michigan but mostly
Michigan off the field and even though
JJ McCarthy's a Heisman candidate but
this really has to do with the sign uh
stealing Scandal and we talked about
Connor stallions resigned or maybe was
fired or whatever it is but he fell on
the sword uh so does this all go away
with Michigan everything's good
now I don't think so Dan I mean you and
I have been around this for a long time
and this is how it always goes right now
whether whether they knew at the upper
reaches of the football building that
Conor stallion was doing this you know
everybody's going to have their own
judgment and have conjecture about
whether that's true but this always
happens whenever you get caught
something there's always some low-level
assistant raises his hand I was acting
alone nobody knew we've seen it in
basketball we've seen it in football I
don't think this makes this go away in
the least the real question is does the
Big 10 you know Implement something in
their sportsmanship policy make gy set
out for a while how long is how long is
the right amount of time who knows and
then be that I think this is something
that stays with Michigan the rest of the
year it feels like what doesn't benefit
the Big 10 or Michigan to have him
punish this season right and hey Jim
take the month of September off again
next year yeah that is Dan you know
that's the thing very few people or
institutions particularly act against
their own best interest and punishing
Harbaugh does act against the big 10's
interest what I have found interesting
about this is that the other coaches and
ads have apparently in these meetings
have been so adamant about Michigan
being punished the reason that surprises
me is that typically coaches may be so
angry about something but they're not
doing that because well they might might
not be stealing signs there's something
they don't want you poking around in
their business about and you're inviting
people to come scrutinize you when you
become that adamant about punishing
someone else so I've been surprised by
that and that's the only reason I think
the Big 10 would act now because
otherwise you're 100% right it's not in
the big 10's interest to try to punish a
team that might well win the national
championship how do you explain the
market correction with
Colorado um line play teams catching up
a little bit a little bit of wear and
tear of the season and I don't want to
diminish what they did because they are
so much improved from what they were
prior to Dion's arrival he's done a
really good job even if they don't win
another game in terms of
improvement but you go back and look and
you know TCU is not very good Nebraska's
not very good and USC can't stop anybody
but you know I give Colorado Credit
because in the past they still would
have lost those games too so I think
it's just part of the building process
and we probably um probably thought he
was a little farther along than he was
capable of being than anyone was capable
of being with the they got off to
talking to ree Davis College game day
will be in Athens next Saturday Old Miss
at Georgia the show live from 99: to
1200 Eastern and uh also Reese will be
hosting the college football playoff
ranking show which you can catch
tomorrow night 7 Eastern on the Mother
Ship who's going to be number one this
week in your opinion I think it's going
to be Georgia Dan because um Ohio State
certainly last week had the best resume
and they probably still do but I haven't
thought that they were the best team yet
and Georgia
uh good win over really good Missouri
team I would suspect that there were a
number of people on that committee who
thought they were the best team already
but needed something you know just
needed something to validate it and
maybe that went over Missouri will be
enough combined with Ohio State's
struggle against you know solid
improving but certainly not Juggernaut
Ruckers team I think we'll put George at
number one but then again I thought
Georg would be number one last week too
despite Ohio State's better resume the
fall at USC why did it take this long
for Lincoln riy to realize what the
problem was I think he realized it and
just didn't want to quack an assistant
coach in the middle of the season and
then it became just an untenable
situation um I I think linol has to have
realized it because they didn't improve
at all from last year now they look they
got pressure on the quarterback they're
up they've been up and tackles for loss
and Sack that doesn't really matter if
somebody just lines up hand hands the
ball to somebody and they just run
through you continuously you don't get a
chance to get that many sacks so they
didn't show a lot of tangible
Improvement it was it's keeping them
from being a championship Contender and
I thought the thing that made it
imperative to make the move and maybe
it's misleading because we all know
little clips of video can be misleading
but Alex Grinch was on the sideline with
the defense during the game Saturday
night he's giving instructions and at
the end he holds his hand up in the
middle for everybody to join hey let's
go go get and they all I mean I think
they all left him hanging so much so
that I felt awful for him but that was
like you know what they're not with you
and I maybe I don't know if that had any
impact or probably he has a larger set
of data to show that the players just
aren't with him and they need a new
voice Alex a good reputation as a
defensive coach at one point and you
know I think probably it's one of those
things everybody needs a fresh set of
downs as C needs a new voice he probably
needs a new place I know Caleb Williams
isn't going to win the Heisman but he
probably uh showcased his valuable
talents even more so this year than last
year because he's had to put up these
numbers theyve they have to score 40
45 but that defense has just let them
down what's your assessment of Williams
this year as opposed to last year I
think that there are areas in in which
he's improved I mean he's got uncanny
accuracy um he's obviously an elite
athlete in addition to being fast he's
slippery sometimes guys are kind of
straight line fast not quite as slippery
he's both he's got a great size and you
know I've thought for a while that you
know he and Drake may it sort of depends
on your preference and flavors of ice
cream you know but both are really good
athletes you know Drake's probably a
little more in that uh Andrew Luck mode
in that he's really fast but not as not
as slippery but both are great players
and you know I think what Caleb has done
to keep his teams in games because it's
you know both of them are in similar
situations I think their defenses have
let them down uh in terms of being able
to compete for championships so I think
we've got a couple of really really high
level quarterbacks at the top of the
draft and I think Caleb is probably one
of those guys Dan that so many off
platform plays unscripted plays in
addition to being able to function very
well within the confines of an offense I
think he's probably the guy you go boy
if we pass on him we're going to regret
it so I think he's going to be uh you
know the number one overall pick and
it's disappointing for him that really
even in his first year at Oklahoma they
just they would come close to a
championship but not quite enough a
complete team not quite a complete
enough team around him to win a
championship is there an atmosphere that
made you nervous on college game
day no uh maybe I'm just maybe I'm just
not a very smart guy from Alabama or
something but it has you know nothing uh
nothing has has really made me nervous
uh yet you know in terms of you know
feeling insecure in a big crowd or
feeling you know overwhelmed by the show
that you're trying to uh deliver in
front of a crowd it's it's sort of
exhilarating you know so maybe I need to
be a little smarter about that but not
not really not yet is uh McAfee gonna be
the villain is that uh his role from now
on you know he's just himself Dan I I've
never I I've never met anybody like him
he's got such a an ability to connect
with people and the crowd responds to
him in a way that I haven't seen and in
my television career he just understands
how to do it and you know my my wife my
wife's aunt is 88 years old right so
she's a loyal Watcher of the show first
because she's a college football fan and
hopefully because she tolerates me and
when and when pat first came along she
didn't have any idea who he was you know
she's like who is this wow I don't know
if I like him and now
I think that she likes him better than
she likes me I mean you know she she
watches every she loves him and uh you
know so he has an ability to win people
over who might doubt and he's able to
connect and I mean he's he's been a
fabulous teammate so I've been happy to
have him so he but he's not afraid if he
needs to be the villain and something he
believes he is not afraid safe travels
to Athens great to talk to you again ree
all right Dan thanks a lot all the best
to you my friend ree Davis he is the
host of college game day and they will
be in Athens Georgia it's Old Miss at
Georgia also the college football
playoff rankings show you can watch that
tomorrow night at 7 Eastern are we going
to have a new team at the top of the
rankings I believe that we will